so I want to show you how to feel
refreshed when you wake up in the
morning now I'm curious how do you feel
when you wake up in the morning are you
refreshed are you grouchy are you irritable
are you exhausted are you just a little
bit tired go ahead and comment in this
section down below and I'm gonna read
all the comments I'm really curious so
the best way or indication of whether
you really rest it or not I'm not just
talking about sleeping I'm talking about
really resting and feeling rejuvenated
is how you feel when you wake up in the
morning as well as how you feel through
the entire day so the real key and most
important factor of sleeping is the
sleep hormone called melatonin now
melatonin is a hormone that is triggered
by darkness okay so when it's dark at
night and there's less light going in
through the eye and into the brain
you're gonna trigger the pineal gland to
convert serotonin into melatonin make
you tired help you sleep during the day
when it's light out or if you have light
in the room that's going to go through
the eye into the retina into the brain
and turn off melatonin now melatonin is
vitally important for your immune system
and this also explains why when people
don't sleep that well they get sick so
the less sleep you have less melatonin
you have the greater the risk of getting
infections having heart problems and
many other diseases now the other thing
to know is that melatonin is a very
powerful antioxidant so having enough
melatonin can actually help your body
from free radical damage and it can
potentially help extend your life now
the problem with taking melatonin is a
supplement which I don't recommend is
that you're taking a hormone and then
over time your body just produces less
it will compensate so I don't like the
option of taking melatonin as a sleep
aid at all now here's another big
problem with melatonin as you age your
melatonin decreases and this is why when
you get older you just can't sleep as
long and this then increases your risk
for other
the problems also melatonin is a
powerful anti-inflammatory so when you
don't sleep you tend to be more stiff
you have more pain more inflammation
when is the best time to go to bed well
ideally when it gets dark out but you
know that usually doesn't happen but I
would recommend between 10 and 11
o'clock p.m. that would be the best time
to go to bed ideally you have certain
hormone waves too called circadian wave
static that come up and down and they
run about every 90 minutes and so you
want to catch the wave between 10:00 and
11:00 and sometimes when you stay up
especially after 12:00 midnight it might
be more difficult to get to sleep
because you have your second wind which
basically means that you're working
against these waves and sometimes you
have to wait and catch the way before
you can actually get into a deeper sleep
so I noticed a lot of times people are
tired around let's say 9:00 9:30 or even
10:00 and they push themselves they're
watching TV and then all of a sudden
they wake up and now they they're awake
for maybe 90 minutes this is why that
occurs so right now let's talk about all
the things that you can do to enhance
melatonin in your body number one when
you go to bed keep the lights off what
happens when people go to bed they have
all these lights going on they have
their cell phone they might have that
laptop they might have the TV going on
we want to start to shut down some of
these lights and have more dark go into
the retina so just realize the less
lights you have in the room the better
okay so lights out would be number one
number two fluoride just so happens that
fluoride interferes with the pineal
gland it can even create problems with
calcium buildup calcification so get a
good water filter to filter this out
I'll put a link down below for some
recommendations for water filters I've
done some videos on that but tap water
usually has the fluoride in it and as a
side note you might just find that your
skin will be so much better especially
if you have acne number three glycine
okay is an amino acid that has a really
good effect on serotonin and it can
increase serotonin
you would take one to two grams before
bed okay that could help you as well
number four reducing your blue light I'm
talking about the blue light on your
computer screen on your TV screen blue
light can reduce melatonin so you can
get in various sunglasses that filter
out blue light but another way to do
this is just to get the free apps that
you can download on your computer to
filter out the blue light and you'll
notice that be less I string alright
number five you want to get sun exposure
and vitamin D during the day because
what happens is melatonin in the Sun and
vitamin D work kind of like opposing
each other so what we want to do during
the day is we want to turn off melatonin
so it can recharge and at night we want
to turn it on so we don't want to
necessarily live in the darkness so the
combination of Sun vitamin D and
melatonin at night because it's
stimulated by darkness is a very good
way to help to turn off this little
switch that you have going on because
what happens if you just don't get
enough Sun or vitamin D then melatonin
doesn't seem to work at night
effectively number six obviously we want
to reduce stress as much as possible you
want to somehow change your environment
go for a long walks in the park and just
get away from stress because stress will
also shut down at melatonin will
actually cortisol will shut down
melatonin and that's the stress hormone
and of course caffeine will interrupt
the natural production of melatonin as
well alcohol now what's interesting with
this next one is that not only does
darkness stimulate melatonin but cold
will have a stimulatory effect amount of
tonin so if your temperatures cooler
okay in your room you'll stimulate
melatonin so I like to keep the
temperature roughly about 68 degrees I
actually like sleeping when it's a
little bit colder and lastly and most
importantly we're going to talk about
EMS for a little bit okay
electromagnetic frequencies let me just
go to this next board right here this is
a very important topic so what is this
EMF well it stands for electro mad
netic fields so this pertains to the
amount of certain types of frequencies
or energies that are around your space
okay and what we're going to be talking
about is around your body now I don't
want to get too much into the woods in
this video but I do want to talk about a
very important space where you actually
spend 1/3 of your life which is in bed
in relationship to EMFs because you may
find with what I'm about to tell you
that this could be the big reason why
you are not sleeping one of the things
that you can do is you can get a device
I have quite a few and these are EMF
devices and they can pick up different
frequencies on this one it has magnetic
fields and it has electrical fields okay
so that's we're going to be focusing on
with this video we also have radio
fields right here that would be like the
cell phone signals that are coming off
I'm not going to get into that at this
point but I want to talk about
electrical fields and magnetic fields
and I think the best way to explain this
is a water hose okay so if you turn on
the water hose you have this current or
this pressure of water that's going
through the hose right and it's spraying
out so this would be equivalent to
plugging in an electrical cord into the
wall and then turning on the light okay
we have the on switch we have the
electrical current going through and
then we have the light right here so
this is going to generate electrical
fields as well as magnetic fields now if
I turn off this part right here so
there's no more water coming out that
would be equivalent to turning off the
light and you may then think that the
electrical fields and the magnetic
fields will just completely go away but
they don't and you still have voltage or
pressure in that line all you did is you
turn off the light at this end it's
still plugged into the wall over here
same thing with water hose if we turn
off right here we still have pressure in
this line okay why because it's still
turned on over here so let's take a look
at your bed right here okay so you're
sleeping in your bed if your nightstand
and you have your light right here this
light is plugged into the socket you
might have your alarm clock right here
you might even have you
cellphone sitting right here which we'll
talk about in a second so you turn off
the light but guess what
it still plugged in and you're still
gonna have electrical fields and even
magnetic fields that can extend six to
eight feet from the socket now if you
don't believe me just get one of these
devices and go ahead and measure it okay
so first I'm gonna do is I'm going to
turn it to electrical fields okay so I'm
gonna go to the smart board right here
not too bad eh so electrical fields
aren't bad
let's go magnetic biga big magnetic
fields so I have to stand like this far
away so I'll have to try that next time
I try to write on the board right so I
wouldn't want to be hanging out at this
level for too long okay so let's let's
take a look at the radio frequencies now
this is not really you can see it's a
little bit but let's take a look at my
cell phone so I'm holding this here's my
cell phone okay now I'm gonna click on
wake up the email look at that there's
a lot of frequencies coming off that
phone right now right so can you imagine
holding this to your head everyone does
it all that long so you want to keep
this away from your head and use your
speakerphone there's other things you
can do as well but do not do this with
here with your head okay don't touch
this thing in fact when you bought the
phone you even sign something for them
to tell you not to do that okay look at
this on this light that's electrical
field
let's check magnetic fields not too bad
so we're gonna check a light that's off
magnetic fields are low let's go to
electrical fields look at that
that's crazy it's off why is that
because there's still voltage in the
wire there's pressure it's just not
turned down at this level this is why we
want to disconnect the cord at the
bottom don't look into the light right I
mean even this far away you can see that
it's quite high it should be 0.5
Electrical is really high see the wire
is really high
now I'm gonna unplug this light hey
there's nothing now so you can see when
you go to sleep you want to unplug that
or put a switch down here to turn it off
the goal is to reduce the amount of
electrical magnetic frequencies around
your body at night since you spend so
much time you know in your life sleeping
we want to reduce EMFs why because it
decreases the production of melatonin
from the pineal gland in fact it could
decrease your stage for sleep your deep
delta-wave sleep so even though you're
sleeping you're not resting so there's
some very very simple things you can do
okay you can just unplug these devices
to your light and your alarm clock and
just get a battery clock okay or you can
spend four dollars and get one of these
on/off switches that you plug into the
outlet then you can plug in the cord
into these and turn off the power where
the outlet is and that will cut down on
the EMF considerably another thing you
really want to make sure you do is to
take your cell phone and either put it
on the other side of the room or put it
on airplane mode because this cell phone
is emitting a lot of unfriendly energy
to your brain to the heart to your cells
let's keep it really simple number one
turn your cell phone to airplane mode
number two unplug the cords from the
outlets close to your bed or get one of
those little switches that you can turn
it off at this level right here now you
may find if you get a tester that the
cables in the wall are a problem
I'm not gonna go that deep in this video
but I suggest that you do get one of
these devices to measure those fields
and then you can really see the one I'm
going to recommend is the Trifield EMF
meter model tf2 I'm not affiliated with
the company I don't get any Commission's
but this is one of the better ones
because you can measure all sorts of
things around your house I will do a
video on your computer space that's
another area that we need to talk about
because the power cables the surge
protector underneath the computer the
battery backup the lights the printer
all of this will be giving off a lot of
unfriendly energy that can make you very
tired it can affect the heart it can
even cause arrhythmias and a lot of
other problems next one get a
battery-operated clock okay instead of a
plug in you're gonna find that that
little action will actually reduce the
EMF if you have a waterbed get rid of it
the electrical heater in that waterbed
creates a big problem with your body if
you have heating pads that's another big
problem because the electrical fields
that are created from that are very bad
especially if you're sleeping with one
on your back all night long so it may
help your back pain but then create back
pain by creating this electrical field
and then electric blanket really bad
because it puts a whole field around
your entire body not very healthy
now some people are really sensitive the
EMF some people are not but I'm just
talking about the long-term effects that
it can create on your body especially
with your sleep cycles alright guys kind
of rather a long video but I think it's
a very important one thanks for watching
with another amazing recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto
there's no suffering in keto absolutely no
karen and it's an immune system builder
absolutely you have to check this out I
think you should hurry up watch the
recipe and make it yourself it's just so
easy to be keto but is it simple it's
super simple we hope you enjoy making it
as much as we are enjoying eating